hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the expert levels in
Super Mario maker in the hundred mario
challenge that we're doing right now oh
god oh god oh god okay ah she gosh okay
we're fine
how why are you following me why was he
following me oh I pushed the bill okay
we're gonna try that again because
apparently this is going absolutely
bonkers insane hit get down you don't
deserve to be flying okay here we go try
this again
oh nice very nice oh alright okay whoa
whoa come on oh [ __ ] I was doing the P
flying I was flying with my P damn it
okay but at least I got the checkpoint
there so I need to use holy balls
alright I forgot about them so scary
boink nares nice that's nice that's what
I call nice huh okay do I need to take
this with me do I need to take this with
me is that what I need to do ma r oh I
Malloy who's my Roy what's the Roy Bean
who the heck is my Roy I don't know what
that means but someone needs to correct
their spelling and go back to school
anyway I did that so that's good yeah
the world record nice nice what a nice
lovely introduction to this I don't know
if I got any 1ups on that one but at
least I didn't lose too many lives
eighty seven and eight levels well I
can't do math 12 levels left to go cloud
is the way cloud is the way
oopsy poopsy ali noodles gonna be okay
so I gotta be mid bubble patient or it
gonna be faster ha you thought you gonna
beat me the answer was you wouldn't you
were not gonna beat me
boink okay so cloud is the answer I'm
not a hundred percent sure what that
means
and frankly I I don't really want to
know but hope okay everything's fine
everything's fine everything is going
swimmingly for me
who wants some nobody here maybe if I
pop these and take him nah they're still
filled with animal whoo oh god oh god
Hogarth Hogarth Hughes hug hug hug hug
well oh you didn't tell me there was
gonna be something up there what a load
of ass bag so now we should be able to
get by this
I don't what was up there what was up
there to hit me no just a load of
bollocks just oh that thing whatever
that is cuz I was going too slow I still
got my mood thank you for that thank you
for the Boosh I didn't need to be
booshed I've been booshed enough in my
life I didn't even need that why did I
get that why am i chasing after the
cloud is the way I seem to be okay oh my
cloud okay
oh I need to book it I am too slow gotta
go fast come on
I should have jumped I didn't why didn't
I jump whoa whoa whoa so precarious on
that launching sequence once again I
would like to reiterate that how
unnecessary it actually is Oh for you
note down noise we're going we're going
we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna
we're gonna oh god this is a mistake but
it's okay cuz I need this last as long
as possible okay go and go and go and go
and go and go and oh [ __ ] oh god oh god
oh god oh okay I don't know why those
things are able to fly
I mean they're not even flying they're
just kind of going okay there's good
that's good yes yes
I got a one-up whoo this is getting
difficult I mean it was difficult before
but now it's actually getting to the
point where it's stressing me cuz I can
make it through this I can make it
through this but when it gets down to
the wire it's gonna get pretty bad
towards the end of this game when I get
to like level 12 and 13 I'm gonna be
sweating bullets if I keep losing live
like this or if I run into another one
that looks like the one that I came into
the first time I play this in the two
episodes ago oh god what do I do about
that
alright you know what I'm not going
through the door I'm not gonna play your
game
you rogue I'm gonna play my game that
game is mario maker
all right well that worked out
wonderfully he better not be whoa okay
all right okay oh hi Oh goodbye okay so
do I go through that do I go up oh
that's that's that's quick timing yeah
yep
Oh Frick [ __ ] okay I can get this ah so
close
damn it too late what there we go ha
goodbye I don't know where I'm supposed
to be going with this
frankly I don't think that I was
supposed to be able to conquer this this
quickly oh boy
okay goodbye I'll take it I'll take it
it's cool it's fine with me I'm good
with this is they okay my book the
Bowser gauntlet has failed see my thing
was that I was just gonna wait around
until they got so bored that they all
fell over and then I win are these
getting progressively more difficult it
doesn't seem that way but the way the
circles are darkening inside the lava
this sounds bad
oh no I just got horrible flashbacks to
all of Roxas level Oh much better
oh I can't even get that can i oh it's
just all there to taunt me thank you I I
get it I get it and no one likes water
levels so sly not that way so slow all
right well that was fun glad we did that
just just a just a time gating mechanism
to make yourself wait
oh God we're going back in the water
aren't we we're just gonna bounce back
and forth between happy Lala water land
and then horrible lava death just
lava death thank you oh that was too
much don't even try to sass me like that
oh man oh boy Wow not okay I am getting
I I am so scared I am so scared for what
it wants to throw at me I'm so scared oh
that's not good
I don't where I I don't I don't know
where I'm going I don't know what I'm
what I'm doing okay
okay that's that's nice okay past the
Jets what evan of time I can't swim that
fast
oh no okay here we go oh okay no
checkpoints this is a barrage no you do
not know you do not know you do not what
are you doing what do i do what do i do
what do i do what do i do okay it's okay
okay okay whoo okay well okay I know
what it gotta do yes up here yes okay so
far so goo haha okay so far so goo what
is this Oh what is this crap doesn't
make any goddamn sense okay all right
then that was nothing what's the point
oh I can grow Oh God
I can grab that spring though I can grab
that one oh all the way all the way back
but he was so difficult it wasn't
difficult but it was so slow ah bag of
ass I knew what I needed to do when I
needed to do it
are you doing this to me
now we got this I have no idea what to
do with it but I got it so that's good
first step is getting the thing and then
the next step will be using the thing in
the way that the thing is meant to be
used and I don't know what that is holy
crap
okay I lost that spring is that spring
just gone
no that Springs back over there I have a
feeling I need that spring but I don't
know what for because you can't climb
with it that's for sure you cannot climb
with it so I imagine the only thing that
I could see is taking a leap of faith
over this way nope okay I can't figure
it out skipping it oh my god
Ryan's gamepad is so gummed up with I
don't know what I couldn't I couldn't
keep that press down so either way I'm
skipping that one I can't I can't I
can't do I can't do that one so I'm
gonna pick this up in the next episode
because I tried real hard God that is so
sticky what is in there no but thank you
everybody so much for watching us again
because I couldn't figure that out just
couldn't so thank you everybody again
and as always I will see you
next video do I need to react please yes